how many government agents were in the
field
right you mean like entrapment yeah
I think it is legitimate to say how many
police how many federal agents were on
the planes that hit the Twin Towers like
I think we wanted maybe the answer is
zero probably a zero for all I know
right I have no reason I think it was
anything other than zero
but if we're doing a comprehensive
assessment of what happened on 9 11 we
have a 911 Commission absolutely that
should be an answer the public knows the
answer to Vivek did nothing wrong
there's nothing there's literally
nothing wrong with what he said there so
he's asking for the copy of it they
would not give it to him and then they
released this small snippet that is
again taken out of context